speaking of valentine's day how about a
sexy speakeasy date
it's a speakeasy exclusivo to summerlin
we needed something like this over here
welcome to exclusivo an upscale
restaurant within the upbeat el dorado
cantina it's not
classic mexican it's definitely
influenced by it we like to call it um
mexican driven
but
you know we use the classic techniques
we have sopas here we have tamales over
here we have tacos but you know there's
a spin this chartsu is chinese inspired
to seafood tamales squid ink inside the
masa you know something that italians do
with their pasta right and then you know
we do croquettes with you know caviar
lime and things like this to make it fun
beautiful so it's kind of you know
bridging together some a bunch of
cultures i would say
our cocktail menu here at exclusivo is
contemporary classic twist so where we
took the espresso martini and changed it
and made it with chocolate rum
an old-fashioned made with tequila as
well as some twists on sours and
margaritas with passion fruit and guava
and that's just some of the small bites
menu and cocktails we also have a large
format on the menu and we have a whole
branzino that's very popular we have
whole tomahawks
a whole stuffed lobster
those are definitely big hits in the
restaurant another big hit is the design
and decor you make your way up and you
have your main dining room very small i
think everything is about 10 12 tables
and you know there's grand chandeliers
out there it's a very small intimate bar
but great program with what they're
doing back there
um
you have a couple more hidden doors one
is one leading to the restroom and one
of course into this room ah the library
where you can feed your stomach
and your mind where did you get all of
these books let's hear that story so we
did a lot of research on it we tried
looking online doing different things
but we just went to a used bookstore and
they obviously didn't have this many
books for us ready but they had a huge
warehouse out in boulder city where we
went with a few trucks and picked it all
up and
put them in all ourselves i hear you can
open a book and sign it etching your
name into the exclusivo experience
forever
great date night indeed exclusivo is
exactly what its name is exclusive so
the only way you can receive an
experience there you have to call them
at 702-447-05
all right are you staying in or heading
out for the big